Alain Bouchard bonjour bonjour c'est de
la grande visite vous faites rares c'est
rare qu'on vous voit en entrevue vous
aimez pas trop ça bon j'aime pas
tellement ça puis je suis plus rendu là
dans ma vie je voyage beaucoup j'adore
rencontrer nos gens mais j'adore aussi
voyager voir le monde la vie d'Alain
Bouchard ferait un bon scénario de film
renvoyez de la chaîne de dépanneur
Perrette au milieu des années 70 il
allait boucher par bouché manger tout ce
qui bouge dans cette industrie les
couches tard les 7 jours les Perrettes
les provisoires lui et son groupe allait
avaler tous ses concurrents
ce soir de zéro à 50 milliards de
dollars en revenus l'exceptionnel
ascension de Couche-Tard en 40 ans
alimentation couche tard est devenue une
multinationale qui opère dans 26 pays
sous la bannière sur
15000 magasins 124
000 employés Alain Bouchard peut entrer
dans un de ses dépanneurs aussi bien ici
aux États-Unis au Mexique en Égypte en
Irlande ou en cogne
malgré le hibou des couches tard le
soleil ne se couche jamais sur son
empire
est-ce que votre désir d'être toujours
plus gros est encore là il est encore là
certainement au moment où on se parle on
travaille sur d'autres grands dossiers
oui je peux arrêter parce que je fais ça
pour nos gens nos gens aiment se voir
qu'on grandit même ça profiter avec nous
et c'est une motivation absolument
extraordinaire
sur les 15000 dépanneurs qu'il possèdent
près de 11000 la grande majorité donc
sont aussi des postes à essence le géant
aurait-il les pieds sur un seul moins
solide qu'avant comment se préparer à la
décroissance pétrolière
Alain Bouchard a déjà son slogan en
poche aux États-Unis on a un concept FFS
fresh food fat pour nourriture fraîche
et rapide
dépasser les sandwichs emballés des
dépanneurs c'est notre futur la
nourriture
ça prend de plus en plus d'expansion
est-ce que vous êtes en train de
réfléchir à l'autre période qui s'en
vient dans 10 15 20 ans poste essence ou
en tout cas l'essence va décliner
comment ça comment dans votre tête vous
réfléchissez à commencer cette réflexion
là il y a quelques années à Copenhague
pour voir comment le temps qu'on avait
pour se transformer on parle de
transformation ici parce qu'évidemment
lorsque le sens va diminuer ce qui est
ce qui commence je pense qu'on a atteint
on a atteint le maximum là en 2019 pour
nous dans notre secteur pas du pétrole
total mais pour nous 2019 ça a été pas
mal d'année max qu'on pouvait vendre par
site alors maintenant ça a commencé à
stabiliser
ce que ça va se maintenir diminuer je
crois bien ma lecture à moi c'est que le
maximum a été atteint et comment est
prêt pour changer le modèle d'affaires
parce que votre modèle d'affaires actuel
repose beaucoup sur la vente des sens
beaucoup beaucoup oui c'est très
important pour nous en fait on se
transforme avec le marché qui se
transforme lui-même dans le sens les
recharges électriques on a l'avantage
nous d'être en Norvège la Norvège pour
nous c'est notre laboratoire où on teste
beaucoup en Norvège on a on est le plus
gros
détaillant avec des recharges sur nos
sites on a aussi des recharges dans les
résidences on a plusieurs milliers de
résidents qui ont nos équipements c'est
vous qui allez équiper le monde les gens
qui veulent des bornes vous êtes est-ce
que vous venez avec ça ici au Québec
ailleurs dans le monde c'est encore
c'est encore un programme à l'étude il
faut vraiment comprendre comment on peut
fonctionner parce on parle beaucoup de
d'intelligence artificielle présentement
et tout ça est lié avec la consommation
électrique des personnes chez eux
comment on peut les faire économiser en
plus de venir prendre le recharge chez
nous et utiliser la recharge pour leur
voiture à la maison
il y a beaucoup de sujets là parce que
vous les gens venaient dans trois quarts
de vous établissements à peu près venez
faire le plein arrête achètent des jeeps
de la liqueurs
s'ils viennent pas faire le plein il
faut qu'il vienne pour quelque chose
est-ce que ça vous angoisse quand même
on a beaucoup de clients qui viennent
pour eux qui viennent chez nous pour
acheter des produits qui viennent pas
faire le plein qui viennent soit à pied
ou avec leur auto je stationne achète
des produits et retourne c'est pas
toujours la même transaction ou le même
objectif
beaucoup de gens viennent faire le plein
et en pas dans le magasin
la majorité en fait mettre la carte dans
la
pompe une entreprise
alors c'est pas le même mais c'est pas
la même visite mais vous avez quand vous
fermez les yeux vous avez quoi 10 15 20
ans avec le modèle actuel à peu près
puis après
l'Empire peut-il rester aussi fort
autrement il y aura d'abord une
consolidation comprenez que
les voitures à combustion sont là pour
encore très longtemps
en Norvège par exemple
plus de 80% des voitures vendues depuis
deux ou trois ans
sont électriques ou hybrides
et nos volumes sont encore très
importants et on commençait à descendre
cette année alors c'est tout récent même
si on commençait à vendre beaucoup de
voitures électriques il y a plus de 10
ans alors c'est long là le cycle donc il
y a une consolidation avant d'avoir une
extinction du genre ça va prendre
beaucoup de temps mais oui ça va arriver
alors il faut se préparer il faut se
transformer il faut réorganiser nos
commerces pour vendre autre chose pour
attirer les clients autrement pendant
longtemps Alain Bouchard a été regardé
de haut par le Québec King sauf par une
personne Pierre Péladeau qui l'invite à
faire partie de son conseil
d'administration monsieur Péladeau a
même prédit que Bouchard allait le
dépasser en affaire
il a en fait dépassé tout le monde
alimentation couche tard valait ce
mois-ci grosso modo 60 milliards de
dollars avec ses 12 % c'est-à-dire plus
de 6 milliards sans faire la personne la
plus riche au Québec
au début on vous regardait de haut à
l'emboucheur les années 80
les gens du monde
on veut gaspiller de l'argent or
aujourd'hui c'est plus qu'une revanche
que vous avez fait la preuve que quand
les persévérants on peut y arriver en
fait mon rêve à l'époque c'était
d'entendre les gens à dire moi je vais
au couche tard
plutôt que au dépanneur qui est le nom
commun de notre industrie qui est
correct aussi mais je vais au costard et
on est rendu là on est rendu là avec
sherlocker notre marque mondiale et
couche tard ici au Québec alors
c'est pas une revanche comme une très
grande satisfaction parce que dans des
cocktails quand les gens
je leur disais ce que je faisais ils
cherchait à parler à quelqu'un d'autre
alors les gens vous snober Street les
financiers vous snobaient la Banque de
Montréal vous l'avez demandé ils ont pas
accompagné vous êtes avec la Banque
nationale québécoise puis si la revanche
aussi des francophones en quelque part
peut-être pour moi ma satisfaction
c'était de bâtir de créer quelque chose
de solide avec mon histoire avec mon
père
c'était tellement moi là de faire
quelque chose de gros et solide
il y en a pas rien scientifique dans le
sol mais c'était vraiment présent à tous
les jours
il a 9 ans quand son père fait faillite
la famille perd tout et part sur la côte
nord de cet événement Alain Bouchard
retient deux leçons vitales pour la
suite des choses contrairement à son
père il voudra toujours être bien
entouré et deuxième découverte
fondamentale apprendre à aimer la nature
le bois et la pêche notamment vous avez
jeune à 9 ans vu votre père chuté en
affaires ça ça a été marquant pendant
l'impression Alain Bouchard que c'est
votre moteur
principal c'est d'aller venger votre
père aussi beaucoup là un peu de sort
encore là vengeance c'est un gros mot
mais c'est plus de réaliser mon père
avait un rêve de réaliser quelque chose
de bien ce qui avait fait mais les
circonstances ont fait que tout perdu
pas faute d'effort alors pour moi
c'était de bien m'assurer très bien
m'entouré parce que c'est ce qui lui a
manqué d'être bien entouré pour moi ça a
été ma moto là
la longue date et j'ai été très chanceux
on a quatre fondateurs dans cette
entreprise-là
RealFlow de Richard Fortin et Jacques
Damour vraiment c'est des amis on va à
la pêche ensemble on fait des sorties
ensemble
pas seulement des partenaires d'affaires
c'est devenu de grands amis
et est-ce que justement la propriété de
Couche-Tard
le contrôle devrait agir de coucher vos
restes au Québec ou il y a toujours un
danger de se faire choper
ce serait assez difficile d'acheter
couche tard je montrais à 80 90
milliards alors c'est pas facile
d'acheter Couche-Tard et c'est une c'est
un commerce où ça prend une grande
expertise même si on peut penser que
c'est simple de gérer un commerce de
proximité c'est très complexe dans la
quantité
donc on est à l'abri il faudra qu'il
arrive quelque chose que je contrôle pas
mais je le vois pas
c'est un empire c'est pas exagéré dans
votre cas de dire que c'est un empire
qui va rester sous contrôle québécois on
peut dire ça
on peut dire ça
je peux pas contrôler les les
aspirations de des actionnaires
mais partenaires on a une entente
ensemble qu'on veut rester ensemble mais
on vieillit tous c'est les familles vous
dites on continue à acheter on continue
à se joindre des gens vous avez voulu
acheter une très grosse bouchée
Carrefour en France au chapitre économie
le gouvernement s'opposera à tout rachat
des supermarchés Carrefour par un groupe
canadien est-ce que vous remercier
aujourd'hui Emmanuel Macron de vous
avoir empêché parce que vous alliez
aller peut-être dans un autre domaine
qui est pas tout à fait le vôtre ou
vous l'avez encore sur le coeur vous
aimeriez avoir Carrefour en fait je
remercie pas du tout
monsieur Macron d'avoir agi comme il
agit
pour nous c'était très réfléchi cette
démarche là on avait un entente avec les
gens de Carrefour le deal était fait
25 milliards il fallait faire
la revue diligente il fallait aller
rencontrer le gouvernement mais
eu des fuites on a appris avec la France
que la confidentialité c'est pas c'est
pas comme si on voit ici en Amérique où
les règles sont très sévères là-bas tout
le monde parle et sa sortie
prématurément très prématurément donc
c'est un très beau projet c'était un
projet extraordinaire mon plan c'était
de consolider les grandes surfaces dans
le monde pas en Europe dans le monde
alors Carrefour aurait été notre point
de départ je le vois je l'ai vu dans vos
yeux ce qui vous anime puis vous êtes en
train encore de dire ça aurait dû être
fait est-ce que ça va est-ce que c'est
possible un jour
pas vraiment pas vraiment
il y a des timing dans dans les
acquisitions il y a des timing en
affaires il y a des rationnels qui se
font qui que lorsque ce timing là est
passé
terminé
en sens là c'est terminé ça sera autre
chose
il y aura autre chose parce que vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure vous la
crainte d'être trop grosse pas quelque
chose que vous avez non pas du tout pas
du tout non
je n'ai pas cette crainte là vous avez
institué établi une culture chez vous ça
c'est fascinant dans le livre
vous dites il faut que les employés
soient capables de se responsabiliser de
prendre des risques d'avoir un esprit
d'initiative de poursuivre aveuglement
les règles hiérarchiques pour vous là
c'est pas un détail c'est fondamental ça
c'est très important depuis la journée 1
en fait c'est une question de confiance
en l'être humain c'est assez simple moi
je regarde ce qui est au dessus des
épaules la personne à qui je parle
comment elle pense comment elle agit que
quels sont ces motivations ces valeurs
et en général
les gens qui viennent travailler à tous
les jours ils veulent performer ils
veulent se retrouver dans un ambiance où
ils ont du plaisir ils veulent se
réaliser ils veulent pas juste prendre
leur salaire afin de la semaine c'est
assez rare peut-être au gouvernement
mais en tout cas chez nous
et pour ça quand on
pense comme moi mais on fait en sorte
que ça arrive c'est simple comme
principe difficile à appliquer mais ça
fonctionne j'ai appris le mot en anglais
tard dans ma vie un port une
responsabilité responsabiliser les gens
leur donner du pouvoir c'est assez c'est
une mauvaise traduction mais c'est ça
exactement leur donner du pouvoir puis
ils sentent mieux à travailler mais ça
veut dire que le patron donc vous le
ciment vous devez tolérant à l'erreur
bien sûr bien sûr j'avais un employé que
j'ai accompagné dans la mort quelques
années Robert Robert qui est venu
travailler pour nous et qui a fait des
erreurs et là
ici là on peut pas fonctionner écoute à
l'unan je me suis trompé ça arrive plus
d'accord ça vous aimez ça c'est parfait
continue Robert
comment passer à travers la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre comme grand pâte comme
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ça c'était
très très difficile
la pandémie
exacerbée ce problème là ça a été
vraiment été encore un problème
important pour nous moins difficile que
d'autres entreprises parce qu'on a une
culture très forte mais c'est pas
suffisant c'est pas suffisant on est
quand même dans un secteur où on peut
pas payer des salaires
extraordinaires on permet des carrières
on ouvre des horizons à nos gens de
progresser à l'intérieur de l'entreprise
qui nous aide beaucoup
vous croisez le Premier ministre des
ministres vous leur dites quoi qu'est-ce
qu'on fait qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
pour ici au Québec je pense que c'est le
problème est plus sévère parce qu'on
aurait dû le nombre dans un train le
moins
d'immigrants qu'on le veuille ou non la
population vieillit je comprends que on
voudrait avoir des salaires de 60 70
000 partout mais c'est pas la réalité si
on fait pas face à la réalité on a un
vrai problème là vous dites monsieur
Legault desserré un peu les yeux ouvrez
les portes un peu bien sûr
on peut les franciser mais oui on peut
les franchiser on le fait constamment on
donne des cours à nos gens beaucoup plus
que d'autres types d'entreprises mais ce
qui disent à contrario ceux qui disent
mais les chefs d'entreprise c'est sûr
puis on entend la Chambre de commerce
qui répète ça tout le temps ils veulent
plus immigrants parce qu'ils veulent
passer moi l'expression épouvantable ils
veulent du chiper ils veulent à Baume à
bas prix qu'est-ce que vous répondez à
ça du tout on veut de la main d'oeuvre
voilà
en forme nos gens on leur donne des
opportunités de carrière moi ils ont
donc c'est absolument ridicule ce
bouchon vous êtes des fois vous êtes le
premier des fois que vous êtes le
deuxième québécois le plus riche facile
les gens
vous est-ce que ça a changé votre vie
d'être à ce point riche ou dans le fond
j'ai l'impression que vous travaillez à
peu près comme vous travaillez avant de
vous
que ça change
ce serait
prétentieux que ça a pas changé ma vie à
l'envers de prétentieux je sais pas en
tout cas
ouais ça serait trop vous êtes libre
en fait ça a changé évidemment mais
j'ai pas besoin de temps que ça dans le
sens que
on mange trois fois par jour on couche
dans un lit à la fois
j'avais pas changé beaucoup les voyages
pour moi les voyages
ça a changé beaucoup là je peux voyager
je peux aller où je veux voir le monde
pour moi ça ça a beaucoup changé mais en
dehors de ça pas vraiment vous avez pas
le goût du luxe je vous avais pas des il
y a des châteaux en Espagne des
non non j'ai pas ça puis ça m'intéresse
pas vraiment
j'ai le goût d'aller à un endroit je
m'appelle un bel hôtel puis vous avez
une fondation oui
très fier de notre fondation pour la
paralysie cérébrale votre fils souffre
de paralysie cérébrale
ça j'imagine que ça vous empêché de
décoller de la vraie terre de la vraie
réalité les regarder
on arrive d'un voyage de deux semaines
avec lui
Jonathan et il est il est formidable
mais vraiment je l'adore mon fils si
j'avais une pilule demain pour lui
donner pour que son handicap disparaisse
pense pas que procéderai parce que ce
serait pas lui rendre service il est
tellement heureux cet enfant-là enfin il
y a 45 ans maintenant et il me rend
heureux et égoïstement et c'est un
enfant qui il est
handicap intellectuel léger alors il y a
un très bon raisonnement il nous ramène
sur la terre constamment en tout cas moi
il m'a ramené beaucoup alors
Jonathan c'est une de nos missions
évidemment pour la Fondation la
déficience intellectuelle et les arts on
donne beaucoup dans les arts aussi on
adore donner mais donner justement dans
le sens avec avec une façon de nous de
livrer quelque chose une prestation pas
de donner sans regarder alors beaucoup
de grandes fondations familiales sont
rendus là maintenant on donne mais il
faut voir ce qui est fait avec l'argent
ce Bouchard on va aller à côté de c'est
à côté d'ici
on va faire ça
bienvenue chez vous
vous entrez des fois incognito ça vous
arrive de
m'arrive et parfois me reconnaît
mais de plus en plus on me reconnaît pas
bonjour bonjour bonjour
vos yeux regardent partout j'imagine
vous inspire
c'est eux qui font arriver les choses
mais ensuite évidemment si la
marchandise comment les gens circulent
et dès le début vous c'était quelque
chose qui est important c'est là comment
on aménage les magasins c'est pas on n'a
pas n'importe quoi n'importe quoi c'est
comme une obsession presque chez vous
oui parce que j'ai vécu dans les
magasins d'abord j'ai commencé pour
faire être dans les magasins pour moi
j'ai vu observer comment les clients
circulaient dans les magasins alors
vraiment il consomme mettre un produit
là j'ai fait beaucoup beaucoup
d'expérimentation
on a continué à faire ça j'avais posé
des tablettes
pensées est-ce qu'on met ça de sens là
de l'autre sens comment les gens vont
s'approvisionner chez nous comment on va
attirer l'oreille pour les ventes
impulsives l'impulsion c'est encore très
importante dans notre commerce et quand
on dit il y a pas de petites économies
où il y a pas de comment vous faites de
l'argent sur un vendant beaucoup en
négociant avec les fournisseurs les deux
d'abord c'est un commerce de sous
c'est ça que je veux
pas un commerce de dollars
ça devient des dollars parce qu'on en
avant pour 70 milliards par année des
sous l'avantage que l'on a c'est la
surface étant donné que c'est une
surface limitée ça nous permet de
choisir
on peut pas tout prendre alors si tu
veux être là
baisse ton prix mais qu'est-ce qui fait
que vous monsieur Bouchard vous avez
réussi et que d'autres chaînes tu en as
eu plein ont échoué pourquoi vous ça a
marché tant que ça
la proximité avec nos gens
la seule vraiment raison c'est nos
valeurs la culture d'entreprise
ça se résume avec notre monde quand on
est proche de notre monde c'est
difficile de manquer j'ai très difficile
il faut être mauvais pour être très
mauvais pour ne pas réussir quand on
parle à son monde dans les écoutes
surtout quand on les écoute leur parler
c'est une chose mais écoutez ça a
beaucoup de valeur
c'est un principe
mais l'appliquer c'est pas toujours
facile des gens qui se font des grosses
ballonnes ils deviennent plus gros que
la boule et ça ça les influence de façon
négative
faut être humble l'humilité c'est une
belle qualité vous incarnez ça parce que
vous êtes très gros on va se le dire
on le voit elle vous entrez dans un
magasin vous avez la passion du détail
la passion du monde c'est pas vous
n'êtes pas rendu sur notre planète que
vous non non parce que je pense pas
pouvoir y aller ça m'intéresse pas
vraiment
mais notre planète s'il me plaît
beaucoup
bonjour Marie-France ça a l'air très
bien votre nourriture parce que ça
marche
l'anglais le français parlez-moi de ça
est-ce que vous avez la difficulté on
parlait de pénurie de main d'oeuvre tout
à l'heure est-ce que vous employez
parlent bien français partout
parce que le commence toujours avec le
français ça c'est
votre grand patron vous l'avez laissé
pas apprendre le français
j'aurais besoin de lui pour faire
grandir l'entreprise côté pragmatique de
s'occuper de la croissance parce que je
crois
par acquisition c'est un grand défi si
j'avais insisté ce qui aurait fait
probablement que quelques acquisitions
qu'on n'aurait pas pu faire son rôle
c'était beaucoup ça aussi toi des
acquisitions qui le français mais pour
les employés à la caisse une politique
partout les couches tard on parle de
Montréal parce que hier c'est évident là
mais il faut qu'il parle français
dans nos bureaux à Laval c'est français
tout le temps c'est beaucoup de monde on
a on a frappé
non mais j'allais dire
comme ça
merci bonne suivez vous allez continuer
à vous occuper de près de ça tout le
temps tout le temps tout le temps
je n'en parlais avec mon épouse
récemment puis
elle me disait jamais capable d'arrêter
Alain